the bodies were discovered by soldiers
from Chad and easier who liberated the
town from Boko Haram militants last week
they said the victims appear to have
been executed at one side just outside
de masaq most were shot some were
beheaded others had their throats slit
their identities are still for the most
part unclear although one is said to
have been the town's Imam most of the
corpses were mummified suggesting the
killings had taken place some time ago
residents said the town was taken by
Boko Haram militants last November at
least 3,000 people fled only the old and
six stayed behind those remaining told
of the horror of the day Boko Haram
invaded their town the people were in
town when they attacked us they fired at
us we ran away to the bushes but they
continued to fire and they chased some
people to kill them you don't would
appreciate a window up the troops from
Niger and Chad drove out the militants
as part of an international push to
defeat Boko Haram in northern Nigeria
the multinational coalition has made
gains recently putting Boko Haram on a
back foot at the beginning of the year
Boko Haram controlled around 20
government districts an area the size of
Belgium
now it is down to just three as
government troops continue their advance
but the militants still remain dangerous